foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the 10 most powerful
Wizarding abilities in a world full of
magic there's certainly no shortage of
spells and with some Wizards and witches
possessing the ability to create them
that list is only growing but with such
a vast list of abilities spanning a
seemingly infinite number of
functionalities which are the most
powerful I'd also like to just clarify
that we're not strictly discussing
battle scenarios here power can be
defined in a lot of ways and it doesn't
always have to be discussed under the
context of fighting or dueling the
abilities featured on this list may
allow an individual to escape the
mundane at least from a muggle-centric
Viewpoint most will also possess some
sort of utilitarian component bearing a
means of achieving something that is
otherwise unachievable or cumbersome
some these abilities can all be achieved
without the use of additional magical
equipment other than a wand of course
before we get started pause the video
and comment your top 10 or even top 5
down below without further Ado here are
my 10 most powerful Wizarding abilities
10. quranap Texas have you ever been
crammed into a small space with too many
people have you ever not quite been able
to fit into those genes or on the
contrary have you ever been in a
situation where you couldn't quite reach
something where you just needed to be a
little bit bigger this rather unknown
ability can help you there quranap Texas
refers to the ability to shrink and grow
we see this ability in multiple magical
creatures such as occamines and mogues
but there is speculation that this
ability can be honed by witches and
wizards as well one important
distinction to be made however is that
Quran up toxic creatures like okamis
will grow shrink to fit available space
whereas mugs can shrink grow as they
desire I can imagine that only the
second type would be useful 9. the site
the site is an ability held by only a
select few in The Wizarding World and it
refers to the ability to see the future
those who possess this ability are
referred to as seers the site is under
the magical umbrella of divination and
can be Amplified through becoming versed
in things like tea leaves fire Omens
crystal balls palmistry cartomancy
astrology and dream interpretations many
believe that Sears such as civil triloni
were frauds simply pretending to predict
the future but if triloni's track record
is anything to go by this ability is
very much real in the 1993 to 1994
school year Harry meets trelawny
properly for the first time so you may
have chosen to study divination the most
difficult of all magical Arts I must
warn you at the outset that if you do
not have the sides there is very little
I'll be able to teach you books can only
take you so far in this field it's here
that trelawny explicitly warns her class
if you don't possess the sight you won't
get very far in divination at least as
far as making prophecies goes however
I'd imagine it'd still be quite a
fascinating area of study the ability
isn't higher up on the list because
though it'd be tempting to use I'm not
sure I'd want to always know what the
future holds ironically it's also not
very easy to predict when your
predictions will come 8. obliviate
have you ever done something horribly
embarrassing in front of people and
wished that you could wipe their
memories well obliviate aka the
forgetfulness charm is the spell for you
this charm allows the Caster to erase
specific memories from an individual's
mind and was used excessively by famous
fraudster gilderoy Lockhart who erased
the memories of accomplished witches and
wizards and laid claim to their
accomplishments memory charms were
primarily used by the ministry of magic
in response to breaches of the
international statute of secrecy like if
a muggle saw a flying car but the
ability itself was known to many the
major downside to this ability is that
if performed incorrectly it could cause
brain damage
7. accio TV remote too far away want an
edge in your sport than Akio is the
spell for you simply put accio aka the
summoning charm allows the Caster to
summon an object towards them with the
object Claire in the Caster's mind an
object in or out of their line of sight
could be summoned towards them this
ability may seem fairly innocuous
compared to some of the others on this
list but I bet you'd use it more than
anything else 6. horcrux creation Tampa
with the deepest Mysteries the source of
Life the essence of self only if
prepared for consequences of the most
extreme and dangerous kind a horcrux is
an object in which a dark ritual wizard
imparts a piece of their soul in order
to achieve immortality a horcrux can
only be created after committing an act
of murder and is considered to be the
most terrible form of dark magic charms
and jinxers are often put in plays to
further protect Hall cruxes after they
are created and the appeal of them is
that if your main physical form is
destroyed your sole existence lives on
in these objects
eternal life at your fingertips is
certainly incredibly powerful but I'd
imagine that most wouldn't want it which
is why it's lower down on the list 5.
invisibility have you ever been at the
grocery store and seen someone walk in
that you do not want to talk to when
you're out of the house and vulnerable
to unwanted conversation there always
seems to be someone lurking around I
can't be alone here well if you're
anything like me then this ability may
come in handy invisibility refers to the
ability to be unseen by others despite
actually being there there are a few
ways of going about this in Harry Potter
with the most known method being via the
invisibility cloak one of the three
Deathly Hallows but there is a way of
achieving this without any kind of
equipment the disillusionment charm this
useful charm the Dumbledore's fond of
results in the Caster taking on the
exact colors and textures of their
environment much like a chameleon the
result is that you are basically
invisible for flying but not the broom
kind of flying I said no equipment I'm
talking about unsupported flight and
then Harry saw him Voldemort was flying
like smoke on the Wind without
broomstick or thestral to hold him his
snake-like face gleaming out of the
Blackness his white fingers raising his
wand again JK Rowling is reported to
have stated that all wizards have the
power of flight innately but that the
vast vast majority need a broom to
achieve it in Voldemort's case he was so
focused and Powerful that he was able to
channel the power to fly unsupported
harnessing the energy through himself
rather than the broom Snape was also
able to learn this ability
using absolutely no equipment to launch
himself through the air I don't know
about all of you but for me flying would
come in handy all the time Mr bus fly
going on a trip fly we also certainly
can't ignore the fact that flying would
be great fun 3. Transfiguration
shape-shifting Transfiguration is
defined as the art of changing the form
or appearance of an object or person of
the abilities on this list
Transfiguration is by far the most
diverse as there are many forms of magic
that fit under this umbrella however I
want to focus on the branches of
transfiguration involved with changing
the appearance of people otherwise known
in the Muggle world as shape-shifting
animagus refers to a witch or wizard who
is able to transform into an animal at
will becoming an anime guest is a
learned skill and the witch or wizard
who possesses this ability does not have
the power to decide what animal that
animagus form will be
metamorphmakers refers to a witch or
wizard born with the ability to
transform change their physical
appearance at will metamorph magai can
change their entire physical appearance
like an animagus but also possess the
ability to hone in on specific parts of
their appearance and change only those
things this is an extremely Advanced
ability reserved for a fortunate few
like I said earlier Transfiguration is
far too broad an area of magic for me to
include all of it but if I had to pick
an area of transfiguration to have as an
ability I definitely go with shape
shifting 2. teleportation
teleportation also known as Apparition
in Harry Potter is a magical means of
transportation where the Caster is able
to instantly travel from one location to
another it's a fairly Advanced skill
which not all witches and wizards are
able to perform and for those that
attempt it but don't quite get it right
they can be dire consequences many
witches and wizards simply prefer
conventional means of Transport like
brooms flu powder and Port keys but for
those special few that have honed this
ability and enjoy doing it Apparition is
certainly the way to go from a
utilitarian standpoint it doesn't get
much better than being able to instantly
transport to your desired location with
the snap of your fingers if I had to
choose a magical ability from this list
for myself this would probably be the
one one legilimency mind reading the
mind is not a book to be opened at well
and examined at leisure thoughts are not
etched on the inside of skulls to be
perused by any Invader the mind is a
complex and many layered thing fossa or
at least most minds are it is true
however that those who have mastered
legilimency are able under certain
condition
to delve into the minds of their victims
and to interpret their findings
correctly mind reading or legilimency is
essentially the art of magically
navigating through people's minds this
massively invasive ability allows you to
see into people's minds and read their
thoughts while disability is accessible
to any witch or wizard only few have
mastered it with Voldemort being an
expert on the subject using his skill in
legilimency Voldemort could almost
always tell who was lying to him and
often knew what you were thinking before
you uttered a word only incredibly good
liars like Severus Snape and narcissism
Malfoy were able to lie to Voldemort
successfully the counter to legilimency
is occlimency which is the practice of
magically closing one's mind against
legilimency with the exception of
Severus Snape and Dumbledore Voldemort
was basically able to access anyone's
mind if he so design dead as invasive as
it is reading the thoughts of others is
certainly one of if not the most
powerful ability in The Wizarding World
as if you know what people are thinking
you have the power to control almost
anybody
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of my list what would you
change are there any abilities that I
missed leave a comment down below if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember words are in my not so
humble opinion are most inexhaustible
source of magic